okay another small little laundry hick  my sister made me this super cool little  odd sock bag so most people have ones  that are this size that can store like  one sock well we have a giant family so  i have a giant sock bag so you can see  and what i do is i put all the socks in  there until i you know need you know i  need to go through and sort them and  when i finally have enough that i can  sort them then i sort them out by color  and then what i do is i put the extras  back in here with a rubber band by color  so then if i'm looking for an odd sock  to match a black one for example i've  got this whole group and i can easily go  through and see which one it matches so  just another simple little little hat